週刊「Life is beautiful」2026年7月14日号をお届けします。
今回のテーマは、AIアシスタント育成ツール、トランプ・アカウント、AI時代の働き方、Tesla車を買う理由の変化、NVIDIAとPalantirの提携についてです。
まずは「こんしゅうのざっくばらん」についてです。
今回は、AIアシスタント育成ツールについてお話しします。
先しゅう、MulmoClaudeを何と呼べば良いか悩んでいるとお話ししましたが、ようやく「エーアイアシスタント育成ツール」という答えにたどり着きました。
エーアイアシスタントとは、私たちの仕事や生活のあらゆる分野で24時間サポートしてくれるAIのことを指します。
これとは異なるのが、特定の職務を代行する「エーアイエージェント」です。
それから、エーアイアシスタントは特定のデバイスに依存しないことも重要です。
エーアイアシスタントが活用されるためには、使う本人について深く知り理解している必要があります。
これには過去の会話や予定表、住所録、ToDoリスト、メール、ミーティングメモ、日記などの個人データへのアクセスが必要です。
オープンエーアイやアンソロピックがGhatGPTやClaudeにメモリー機能を追加しているのは、そのためのものです。
それに対し、「エーアイアシスタント」を特定のサービス・プロバイダーにまるごと任せてしまうのは慎重になるべきです。
長く使えば使うほど、切り替える際の負担が増し、一度依存してしまうと離れられなくなります。
MulmoClaudeを使えば、自分のパソコン上で「エーアイアシスタント」を育てることができます。
MulmoClaude自体がオープンソースで、自分のデータも進化の方向も100パーセント自分で決められます。
この「エーアイアシスタントを育てる」という感覚は非常に大事です。
インストールしたばかりのMulmoClaudeにはデータがなく、独自のアプリもないので、そのような状態では「エーアイアシスタント」の役割を果たせません。
MulmoClaudeと自然言語で会話し、自分専用のアプリを作りながらデータを蓄積して行くことが「エーアイアシスタント」の正しい育て方だと思います。
エーアイをうまく使うことで、これからますます大きなギャップが生まれることは間違いありません。
ぜひMulmoClaudeをインストールし、自分専用のエーアイアシスタントを育ててください。
続いて、トランプ・アカウントについてです。
先しゅう、トランプ政権が発表したプランに驚きました。
これは「Trump Account（トランプ口座）」と呼ばれ、2025年1月1日から2028年12月31日に生まれた子ども全員に連邦政府が1,000ドルを拠出するというものです。
この資金は低コストのイーティーエフで運用され、18歳まで引き出せず、その後はIRAとして扱われます。
教育費や住宅購入に使用されることも想定されています。
この制度は「子どもの頃から株式しじょうに参加し、資本主義の恩恵を受けられるようにする」ことを目的に共和党によって推進されました。
ただ、裕富な家庭ほど恩恵を受けやすいとか、トランプ氏の名前をつけた売名行為だとの批判もありますが、制度としては悪くないと思います。
そして、AI時代の働き方についてです。
先しゅうの質問で「AIを使いこなせる人たちになるためには、今のうちに何をすべきか」とありました。
ChatGPTを使っているだけでは、AIを使いこなせるとは言えません。
実際にAIを使い、効率的に仕事を進めるためには、具体的な方法が必要です。
Claude Codeを活用してコードを書き、Gitを組み合わせて作業を行うことをお勧めします。
Gitはソースコード管理のために作られたツールですが、資料管理にも役立ちます。
GitHubと連携することで他人とも共有でき、生産性が向上します。
Gitを学ぶには、ChatGPTやClaudeに質問しながら実際に使ってみるのが近道です。
次に、Tesla車を買う理由の変化についてです。
TeslaのFSDが「人間の運転手よりも安全」なレベルに達し、それが売上にも繋がっています。
運転は多くの人にとってストレスであり、特に疲れた帰宅時などにFSDは大きな助けになります。
月額99ドルの利用料で、自分専用の運転手が得られると考えれば、コストパフォーマンスは悪くないです。
Elon Muskがトランプ氏を支援し、その結果Teslaの売上が停滞していましたが、FSDの価値が理解されることでTesla車の購入理由になると期待しています。
[EN]NVIDIAとPalantirの提携についてです。
[/EN]
エヌビディアとPalantirが提携を発表しました。
[EN]Palantirは、エヌビディアのオープン・ウェイトなモデルNemotronを活用し、クローズドなエーアイモデルに頼らないエーアイサービスを米国政府に提供することを宣言しました。
[/EN]この提携によって、エヌビディアはオープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグルのエーアイサービスに依存しない形で、Palantirを通じて米国政府にサービスを提供しようとしています。
その他に、私の目に留まった記事についてもお話しします。
Teslaは、Optimusの部品について具体的な調達目標をサプライヤーに提示しました。
初年度から年産10万台を目指しているようです。
中国がヒト型ロボットの生産で世界を圧倒し始めているという投稿もありました。
そして、SyntiantがIPOを申請し、エッジエーアイ半導体市場の動きに注目が集まっています。
この先、デバイス上で動くエーアイがより広がることは明らかです。
エヌビディアと競争する市場で低消費電力を強みとする企業に投資するのも一つの戦略と言えます。
最後に、質問コーナーです。
例えば、エーアイ創薬における本質的なお金の流れとして、開発コストが劇的に下がることで、エーアイ技術を提供した会社に利益が流れるといった質問がありました。
これに関しては、エーアイ技術の利用が進むことで、創薬の効率化が進むと考えられます。
それでは、次回も楽しみにしていてください。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。